[Music]
on this tuesday night quebec's anti-vaxx
tax
a tough new tactic targeting people who
refuse to get vaccinated it put a very
important burden on our healthcare
back to school jitters we know the virus
likes lots of people in indoor settings
frayed nerves before five more provinces
resume in-person learning
a covid ravaged first nation overwhelmed
undersupported and disappointed with
ottawa they did diddly squad they have
done nothing for this community who's
stepping up to help
and saving his bacon
we've never done this in a human the man
who has a new heart and a new life
thanks to a pig
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
quebec premier is taking a new approach
in the push to convince everyone to get
vaccinated against covet 19. francois
lego says those who refuse will face a
significant financial penalty they'll be
charged an extra fee for health care the
premier says only those with a valid
medical reason will be exempt from
paying it is clearly aimed at punishing
those who choose not to get vaccinated
and end up hospitalized there are now
more than 2 700 people in the hospital
with the virus in quebec the highest
number since the pandemic began about 10
percent of eligible people in quebec are
unvaccinated but they take up about half
the beds in hospital
the premier says there are health care
consequences to not getting vaccinated
and those who make that choice should
have to pay mike armstrong explains what
the premier is planning and the reaction
it's getting jose
quebec's premier says he's feeling a
grumbling in the population
a growing frustration that a small
percentage of people refusing to be
vaccinated are putting the health care
system at risk i think it's normal that
the majority the population is asking
that there be a consequence
now what that's going to mean is a sort
of tax or at least a bill anyone who
doesn't have an approved medical
exemption from being vaccinated will pay
what francoise is calling a health
contribution he says the application
still being worked out as is the amount
lego will only say that he wants it to
be significant and that
fifty or a hundred dollars for him
wouldn't be significant i think it will
be divisive bioethicist kerry bowman
calls himself as pro-vaccine as possible
in fact he calls getting vaccinated an
ethical obligation protecting the health
care system and people around you is
that important but bowman says finding
people who refuse to get vaccinated is
effectively making vaccines mandatory
something he's against
it may also push people already fighting
health measures to even more anger i
mean how much civil unrest do you want
to create
you know how many people do you want to
alienate obligatory vaccination is
clearly a violation of the charter human
rights lawyer julius gray says this new
health contribution would very likely be
challenged in court the problem is he
says both sides would have strong
arguments predicting a winner he says
would be a toss-up it's a very serious
violation of individual integrity but at
the same time there is an argument in
favor of
putting an end to the pandemic they put
a very important burden now one thing
the announcement may have done for the
premier is change the headlines quebec's
national public health director resigned
suddenly monday night there's also
growing frustration over the
province-wide curfew the ghost says the
government's reviewing whether to lift
it next week
mike armstrong global news montreal
in ontario a record number of coveted
positive adults were admitted to
hospital icus in the past 24 hours 80
people were admitted yesterday alone the
most in a single day since the pandemic
began there are now 477 people in
intensive care in ontario more than 3
200 people are in the hospital with the
virus up 753 from yesterday
there is some good news the health
minister christine elliott says patients
sick with omicron are spending fewer
days in intensive care than those with
delta
the length of stay in intensive care
units is decreasing slightly with the
median stay currently 7 compared to 20
days during the peak of delta
elliott says 83 of all patients in
intensive care in ontario have covet 19.
well the other strain on the hospitals
is a shortage of staff thousands of
health care workers are either
self-isolating or have quit today
ontario announced it will hire
internationally educated nurses to work
in hospitals and long-term care
facilities which need support ontario's
health minister says more than 1200
applicants have already expressed
interest in the program she says they
will begin to be matched with hospitals
later this week
all of us are committed to making sure
we can give children the best stable
environment over the next few weeks that
we can that will remain flexible
and adaptable as we have through this
that is bc's top doctor she believes
kids should be in school and students in
bc went back to class on monday students
in most of the rest of the country will
return to class next monday as the
omicron variant continues to spread
there is debate about the timing of
sending kids back to in-person learning
eric sorenson reports
ontario schools will reopen to some 2
million children starting next monday
janna king is a teacher and a mom and is
torn i know that it's better for my
students when we're face to face but
it's crazy at school like i shouldn't
have 30 kids in my classroom and she
says a lot of kids don't keep their
masks on and not every classroom has
proper air filters yet but with support
from pediatricians groups ontario is
resuming in-person learning because of
the harm to kids mental health from
staying home we've seen the numbers of
mental health needs rising rapidly we
know that it helps students to be in
school for their mental and physical
health
out west most schools have already
reopened in-person learning is preferred
but house soon depends on the province
in british columbia alberta and
saskatchewan schools return to in-class
learning this week or last in the rest
of the country learning is still
happening mostly online but as of
january 17th manitoba ontario quebec pei
and nova scotia plan to reopen
classrooms new brunswick will stay
online at least till the 24th and
newfoundland and labrador is still
assessing it's not an easy call i don't
know what to do honestly on balance this
epidemiologist favors keeping schools
closed another couple of weeks anything
we do at the societal level
that reduces the strain on the hospital
system even a little bit is going to
have a positive impact but this
infectious disease expert leans towards
opening them instead of saying close
schools why don't we say
create safer schools yet he acknowledges
in ontario there's a risk this is the
largest sanctioned mass gathering event
in the province like you can't ignore
the potential for amplification of the
virus in this environment schools are
just one part of it as covid cases
skyrocket and hospitalizations climb
many provincial plans are in flux we
face many more i don't knows and i'm not
sure today than we have perhaps at any
point
in the in the pandemic journey to now
governments will have to be nimble as
the omicron wave grows and up to 5
million children across the country go
back to school eric sorensen global news
toronto
frustration is mounting tonight in a
northern ontario first nation last week
it asked for military help to manage a
major covet outbreak the community says
it still has not received what it asked
for bearskin lake is a community about
600 kilometers north of thunder bay
nearly half its 400 residents including
the band's chief tested positive for
covet 19 last week quebec also requested
military help and got it since january 3
200 members of the canadian forces have
been deployed at quebec vaccine clinics
charlie angus an mp for northern ontario
tweeted today there are those who count
in canada and those who don't
with almost everyone in bearskin lake
self-isolating few people are left to
chop and hull firewood or deliver food
water and medicine as david aiken
reports the community has relied largely
on the help of neighbors
beerskin lake first nation chief lefty
cameron waterman was busy late last week
pressing auto off for help that's the
message we want to send out to the
government we want boots on the ground
right here in the community but by
saturday he like half of those in his
community had been laid low with covid
nighttime i just sweats and
and
the runny nose and
the whole shebang the chief was too ill
tuesday for media interviews but a
community spokesman said on the weekend
they were disappointed that after asking
for as many as 40 military personnel to
help run the community on january the
third
it was not until january the ninth
sunday that the federal government
responded and then with only six army
rangers at least three of which live in
the community and are just recovering
themselves from covet what canadians are
seeing in the crisis in bearskin lake
is the systemic indifference
from this federal government the liberal
government uh towards
the health of indigenous people
meanwhile others who live in their vast
northwestern ontario neighborhood have
pitched in to help we want to say thank
you to all these
neighboring communities that have
stepped up to
help us
that aid included this snowmobile convoy
packed with supplies that made the
three-hour trek last week from big trout
lake first nation while the disease has
been relatively mild to moderate for the
community
the fallout in terms of the workforce
the day-to-day operations that has been
brutal on the community indeed if
there's one small blessing it's that
bearskin lake and many other first
nations communities in the region had a
strong vaccination program in place
definitely the situation would have been
could have been much worse if it weren't
for the high vaccination coverage rates
in the community as for ottawa federal
officials continue to monitor the
situation in bearskin lake and will
adjust to conditions david aiken global
news
ottawa in quebec there are calls for
more support for people experiencing
homelessness after a man died during a
severe cold snap the 74 year old was
found at an encampment in montreal last
night when temperatures hit minus 26
degrees celsius
last january another man experiencing
homelessness in montreal died in
freezing temperatures just steps from a
downtown shelter
it will continue to happen unless we
create
long-term housing and social housing and
low-income housing
for vulnerable populations
overnight shelters have been asked to
revert to pre-pandemic capacities for
the next few nights the montreal coroner
is investigating the man's death
extreme cold warnings are in place in
parts of quebec ontario and new
brunswick tonight today in montreal the
daytime high was about -21 degrees
celsius that's roughly 14 degrees below
average global news meteorologist
christy gordon joins us now christy is
there some relief in sight
donna we've seen a complete role
reversal across canada over the last
several weeks eastern canada incredibly
mild barely even feeling like winter
whereas western canada extremely cold
some of the coldest temperatures we've
experienced in decades and now that lobe
of arctic air has shifted east and
they'll likely experience that in
eastern sections for the next several
weeks with extreme cold temperatures
dropping down to -20 some of the coldest
conditions they've seen in a couple of
years now the big warm-up across western
canada is going to cause some problems
not only are we going to see a surge in
temperatures rising freezing levels
we've had so much snow in the mountains
that is going to be a problem as well
intense rain expected over the next two
days that rain adds to the snow melt
causing problems so we're concerned
about landslides mudslides we're
certainly concerned about some flooding
in low-lying areas especially regions
that are vulnerable from that storm that
we saw back in november now just to give
you perspective the storm we saw in
november brought almost double the
amount of rain of what we're going to
see with this storm coming so it's
certainly not going to be as intense but
it certainly could cause some problems
for areas that are
still dealing with the damage from that
storm in november donna
okay global news meteorologist kristy
gordon thanks
fresh pleased to help afghanistan coming
up the un's new campaign to help afghans
who have next to nothing
plus partying like there's no pandemic
britain's boris johnson again accused of
breaking the rules
and why robots are delivering food at
the beijing olympics
there's a new development down under
about novak djokovic a new investigation
has reportedly been launched that may
mean he won't compete in the australian
open according to australian media
border officials are now looking into
whether djokovic made a false
declaration on his entry form djokovic
reportedly said he did not travel in the
14 days before flying from spain to
australia for the grand slam
but social media posts appear to show
him in serbia around christmas time
djokovic who is unvaccinated one accord
battle yesterday to have his visa
reinstated and remain in the country
there was a stark warning from the world
health organization today about what
they call the tidal wave of omicrons
sweeping across europe the who says 50
of people in europe could be infected
with omicron in the next six to eight
weeks and with the sheer number of
people getting infected the health
systems are at risk of being overwhelmed
the u.n launched its largest aid appeal
ever for a single country to try to help
stave off a humanitarian disaster in
afghanistan the u.n says nearly five
billion dollars is needed to help keep
basic services running afghanistan was
thrown into turmoil after the taliban
takeover in august and the retreat of
the americans foreign aid payments which
the country long relied on were frozen
the u.n says half the country's
population now faces acute hunger
without this being funded there won't be
a future we need this to be done
otherwise they will there will be
outflow they will be suffering
in addition to the 4.4 billion dollars
needed within afghanistan the u.n says a
further 623 million is needed to help
millions of afghans who fled to other
countries last month the canadian
government pledged 56 million to help
provide emergency food and other
necessities
ahead the bring your own booze party
causing big trouble for boris johnson
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
britain's prime minister is facing the
wrath of his own party and the public
after a leaked email revealed a party
was held in the garden of his residence
during lockdown last may about a hundred
of his staff were invited johnson won't
say whether he and his wife attended but
as crystal commansing reports a string
of conservative mps have openly
expressed anger about the bring your own
booze party
after reports of a party that was byob
today boris johnson was m.i.a the prime
minister has asked for an investigation
and his government came under fire in
parliament
the prime minister retains the
confidence of the people of this country
confidence was not what came across in
the house of commons i think mr speaker
his absence speaks volumes as does he
smirks on the media the public have
already drawn their own conclusions
several mps expressed anger but also
pain
jim shannon was overcome with grief
after explaining his mother-in-law died
alone with covet
at that time i'm sorry mr speaker
[Music]
a government investigation is already
underway into claims government staffers
on multiple occasions in 2020 broke
covet 19 rules the latest gathering in
may revealed by british broadcaster itv
news which obtained a copy of the email
invite sent by johnson's private
secretary this pandemic for me is a
story of two men so one is my 55 year
old dad who is dead having spent 42
nights on a ventilator fighting covert
and no other illnesses the other is a
man who was 55 at the time of his party
boris johnson having survived covered
himself thought it was appropriate to
host a party where you could bring your
own boos the prime minister hasn't said
if he attended that party but mps on the
opposite side of the house will push him
on that wednesday as the prime minister
is expected to take questions in
parliament
crystal gamansen global news
london
a world's first next from pig to human
the heart transplant that pushes the
boundaries of what's possible
[Music]
journalists arriving to cover the winter
olympics in beijing are being treated to
futuristic food service these robot
carts bring dishes straight to diners
dropping them off from the ceiling
armies of robots will provide a range of
services at the games as part of
pandemic protocols to minimize contact
between humans
well we know there's a lot of worrying
news about our overwhelmed hospitals
right now so we wanted to share some
incredible and hopeful news about a
medical first doctors in baltimore
maryland have transplanted a genetically
modified pig's heart into a man it was
the only option left to try to save his
life
it worked though it's too soon to say if
his body will fully accept the organ
there is a huge shortage of human donor
organs and many people die on the
waiting list jackson proskow explains
how this transplant could help change
that
you're looking at a medical first a
revolutionary transplant of a pig's
heart into a person we didn't know
what the outcome might be but it wasn't
going to be worse than traditional
therapy 57-year-old david bennett had no
other option
diagnosed with terminal heart disease he
was too sick to be eligible for a human
donation with less than six months to
live doctors in baltimore offered him a
medical leap of faith it was very
difficult for him
to make this decision but at the end of
the day this was his best hope of
getting out of the hospital and having
somewhat of a normal quality of life the
transplant involved a heart from a
genetically modified pig with some of
its own genes deleted and human genes
added to reduce the risk of rejection we
wouldn't give him a worse outcome if we
had a chance perhaps of striking the
good one
he himself said i want to live and if i
don't you'll learn something three days
after surgery the heart is still beating
bennett is alive transplantation has
always
been conducted in the context of an
organ shortage dr david claussen works
with eunos which coordinates organ
sharing in the u.s
if proven
xenotransplantation could ease the
critical shortage of donors it is an
important step
but it still is only a first step and
there will be you know a long journey
ahead you know to see this through
animal to human transplants have been
tried before chimpanzee kidneys a baboon
heart none successful for more than a
few months
pig organs show more promise
heart valves from pigs are already
widely used in fact bennett received one
of those more than a decade before his
heart transplant he realizes
the magnitude of what was done
and he realizes the importance of it one
man's decision to risk it all has
offered hope to thousands that
life-saving transplants might one day
not involve a life-or-death weight
jackson prosco global news washington
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is elk island national park near
fort saskatchewan alberta we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye